une école candidats zemma à saint denis
un nom qui évoque la candeur de
l'enfance
est ce un hasard ici plusieurs
générations ont usé leurs fonds de
culottes la mémoire de candidats zemma
s'est amusé avec eux ils savent
également non pas du tout l'ancien
professeur qui a travaillé dans l'école
au tout début
c'est la rue jules ferry qui a une école
claquant des mains donc le débat qui a
fait reculer l'éducation nationale
la directrice en hausse et elle
supplante mais là je sais pas un
écrivain philosophe écrivain poète
rayonner parce qu'il ya eu des poèmes
oui ou non du azéma je crois que c'était
un maire
petit dernier d'une famille de dix
enfants candide azéma est né à saint
denis en 1785
après ses études de droit il s'installe
comme notaire et est nommé premier
adjoint au maire à un poste qu'il
occupera pendant 29 ans c'est donc à ce
titre qu'il doit remplacer le maire
souffrent et accueillir le 13 octobre
1848 le commissaire de la république
sarda garriga le contexte est tendu
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
plab il lui sert alors un discours
diplomate en 1856 les maires de saint
denis depuis un an et doit cette fois
accueillir le remplaçant de garrigue à
louis do ré nouveau discours cette fois
il est franc et direct et l'exhortent à
redonner un nouvel élan à l'industrie
qu'à l'agriculture et à la population
pendant son mandat ils remplacent les
trop vétuste éclairage à l'huile de coco
par un nouveau système à réflecteurs
argenté afin que l'on puisse lire
facilement le journal à plus de 6 mètres
du réverbère
mais son temps sa santé défaillir il
abandonne sa charge en février 1852 il
meurt un mois plus tard indirectement
semble-t-il de l'épidémie de variole
ramenés par le navire sophie quelques
mois plus tôt et qu'il aurait épuisé le
fléau aura tué en un an plus de 700
personnes et contaminé quelques trois
mille six cents victimes candidats
zeming avait souhaité que les orphelins
de la maladie reste à la charge de la
commune en signe de reconnaissance
son nom est alors donnée à la future
place de la gare où il avait fait
installer des bancs